encontré algunos documentos son mis
papeles de salida del hospital Después
de la historia
Christine Paul y su pareja estaban
entusiasmados cuando el ginecólogo les
habló de un nuevo método anticonceptivo
que tenía muchas ventajas
se me vendió como algo rápido eficaz sin
tiempo de recuperación
él no tenía que hacerse una vasectomía
yo no tenía que pasar por el
procedimiento de la ligadura de trompas
el procedimiento de inserción de un
dispositivo anticonceptivo permanente
duró 15 minutos se le colocaron dos
micro implantes en las trompas de
falopio pero Christine dice que al poco
tiempo empezó a experimentar distintos
problemas de salud
dos o tres meses después empecé a notar
que tenía dolores abdominales y luego
con los años se me cayó el pelo
se me cayeron las cejas
tenía tanto acné que me dolía la piel
Christine dice que empezó a sufrir
depresión y ansiedad Crónica
afirma que fue varias veces a urgencias
pero los médicos no pudieron ayudarla
ella creía que era culpa del implante
fui al médico muchas veces y solo me
decían que no sabían
es muy frustrante no saber qué es lo que
te pasa y que los médicos tampoco lo
sepan
sabes que algo está mal
pero te dicen que la causa de tus
síntomas no es lo que tú sospechas
Christine se sentía sola y dolorida
recurrió a internet donde por fin
encontró el apoyo que necesitaba
no me di cuenta de la magnitud de lo que
estaba pasando hasta que me unía a este
grupo hay 43.000 miembros
miles de mujeres como Christine
reportaron problemas similares dicen que
los implantes les han robado años de sus
vidas esta mujer en particular dice
todavía estoy abrumada leyendo todas las
publicaciones sentía que estaba loca
cuando hablaba con tantos médicos sobre
mis problemas de salud mi lista sigue
creciendo desde enfermedad celíaca hasta
visión borrosa Es raro Entrar a Facebook
y encontrar hermanas que me entienden
tengo mi primera cita para quitarme el
implante en diciembre Déjenme suerte hay
muchas publicaciones parecidas
entró en el mercado en 2002 en 2013 fue
comprado por el gigante farmacéutico
Bayer por mil cien millones de dólares
pero ya entonces aumentaban las
peticiones de que el implante hubiera
retirado del mercado también se
acumulaban las quejas más de 39.000
presuntas víctimas interpusieron una
denuncia en Estados Unidos Bayern retiró
el dispositivo del mercado en 2018 y
negoció un acuerdo por 1600 millones de
dólares con las demandantes
estadounidenses para evitar un juicio
actualmente tenemos alrededor de 150
clientes Aunque el número aumenta todos
los días
la abogada René vinet conoce muy bien el
expediente issues fue enfermera en
Toronto y lleva varios años recopilando
los testimonios de presuntas víctimas de
ishsher en Canadá estamos en el proceso
de elaboración de nuestro plan de
intercambio de pruebas que consiste en
establecer como vamos a intercambiar
documentación y la divulgación entre
Bayern y todos nuestros clientes
en Canadá Bayern no ofreció
indemnización ninguna a las presuntas
víctimas por el contrario la empresa no
admitió su responsabilidad y dijo estar
dispuesta a defenderse enérgicamente
ante la justicia
Bayer y su equipo de defensa seguramente
harán todo lo posible por disminuir la
suma que deberán pagar por estas
demandas individuales
creo que nos sorprendente
Esa es la naturaleza de los negocios la
naturaleza de la ley creo que el
consenso en todo el mundo es que estos
dispositivos les han causado mucho daño
a las mujeres que se los implementaron
Bayern su sucursales el modelo
empresarial de obtener ganancias y la
falta de consideración hacia las
víctimas es el verdadero dilema moral
aquí
planea pedir a Bayer que indemnice a sus
clientes de acuerdo con lo que declaren
haber sufrido también quiere probar que
la empresa no le reveló todos los
riesgos asociados al implante a la
agencia de salud pública de Canadá
John tazón un ginecólogo en Estados
Unidos dice que ha retirado cientos de
dispositivos y Shore
creo que los médicos tienen buenas
intenciones obviamente o no haríamos lo
que hacemos creo que nos dieron mala
información y confiamos en ella creo que
fallamos como médicos cuando las mujeres
empezaron a acudir a nosotros con sus
problemas y no lo reconocimos De hecho
no solo no lo reconocimos sino que
prácticamente les dijimos que estaban
locas todos los ginecólogos con los que
nos pusimos en contacto rechazaron ser
entrevistados al igual que la sociedad
de obstetras y ginecólogos de Canadá el
Ministerio de salud envió una está por
escrito en la que solo dijo que ha
habido avances el materia de
transparencia y acceso a la información
según Health Canadá más de 8.000
unidades de isur fueron vendidas en el
país antes de que fuera retirado del
mercado en 2017